here's a trivia question do you know
what these are so you may have seen
these before they're called ganga
they're the paper draft of an animation
before it gets redone on a cell sheet or
digitally in the case of modern anime
and later put composite it into the show
proper but what you might not know is
that there is a step before this these
are the versions done by the actual key
animators for a scene at which point
they get handed off to the animation
supervisor for the episode who then
often redraws some or all of the frame
to make it match the rest of the episode
better and while that bit of behind the
scenes knowledge is neat and all the
real fun to be had here is looking at
the differences from Gengar to
correction because some of them are just
nuts like look at this Gengar correction
for example looks pretty normal then we
pull up the original they corrected and
boom or how about this Gengar right here
pretty spectacular work right well let's
see what the animation supervisor has to
say ah